-Leslie Jones is an
Emmy-nominated comedian you know
from her work
on "Saturday Night Live."
Her comedy special
"Leslie Jones: Time Machine"
is currently streaming
on Netflix.
Here's my conversation wit
our good friend Leslie Jones
You made a very -- posted a very
passionate video on Instagram.
Can you just tell us
a little bit
how you feel watching
these protests?
-I feel saddened.
I feel saddened
because, like I said,
I always tell everybody I'm 52
And I've seen a lot of stuff
I was in the riots 30 years ago.
And it makes me sad
because I'm looking at thi
and I'm knowing that
this is not going to work.
Like, it's not going to
do anything.
We have a president
that's standing up there,
calling us thugs
and sending out National Guard
He's not listening to anything
that anyone's going to say
I think the only thing he'
going to listen to is votes.
And this is why I was
telling everybody,
if you're going to change
something,
you have to change it,
you have to fight the same fight
that they're fighting.
You have to get into their ring.
You have to get educated
and you have to vote.
It's just the only way.
It's just -- It's almost lik
I wish we would have pulle
a gangster move
and not did nothing
and just waited until November
and just stormed his ass.
You know what I'm saying?
It's just like -- I'm --
It makes me mad
because all these businesses
the black businesses
that are getting messed up
and people that are
getting hurt out there.
And trust me.
I hear the protesters.
I'm black.
Of course I hear the protesters.
But I'm just knowing
that they're not being heard
-I mean, you do have this
perspective, obviously, of age
But you're talking about
Los Angeles in 1992, right
-'92, yeah.
-And so you're
a lot younger then.
You're obviously very angry.
And what are your memories
of that time?
-I was 22. I was 22.
That's why I understand
the protesters
because it's probably nothin
you could say to them right no
that's going to make them
not want to protest
because there was nothing yo
could have said to me back then.
I was ready to burn it dow
because I was like,
"We got to do something.
There's got to be somethin
that we're doing."
But, you know, at that time,
we really thought
we were doing something.
We really thought,
"Hey, we going to tear this up
They're going to pay attention."
And nothing happened.
The officers got off.
They're probably somewhere
fishing, you know what I mean?
And the city was tore up
for years.
L.A. just really got back to
where it --
The saddest part
is all the businesses,
the black businesses
that got tore down,
didn't get to come back.
Those neighborhoods, you go back
into L.A., are now taken ove
by other businesses,
not black ones.
So it's like -- it's like --
I feel like we burning dow
our own house.
-It must be so frustrating
Obviously not only do you have
the perspective of age,
but you have
a much higher profile now.
Do you feel as though
you can use this profile
to get a message through?
Or do you feel like right no
it's just too loud
to have any signal be heard?
-Man, I don't give a damn.
I'm going to use it.
I'm going to use my platform
to make sure that everybod
understands
the importance of voting.
You know, we have a lot of
people out there that's like
"Why do we need to vote?
What do we need to vote for?
Why don't all of us
just not vote?"
When you don't vote,
you're voting for him.
A non-vote is a vote for Trump
And a lot of people
are making a good argument
"We don't have
nobody to vote for."
Yes, we do.
We have somebody other than him!
We need to get him out.
And then we need to start
realizing what our system
looks like.
I think we all just need t
realize that we're all human
and living on the same Earth and
need to start working together
before we don't have nothing
-We had our friend Michael Che
on the show yesterday.
It was really moving for me to
hear him say that he has never
nor would he ever call 911
because he did not think tha
that was a service
that was for him
or that would make any situation
that he would call it for
better.
What is your --
you know, historically,
what has your relationship
with police
been like on a one-to-one level?
-Well, you know,
like I said again, I'm 52.
And I've lived through
a lot of stuff.
My brother was
a hard-core gangster.
There's been many nights
that I had to go pick him up
in the alley after sheriff
have dropped him off
or beaten him to death,
you know, just beating him up.
They just stop by
and pick him up,
throw him in the car,
and beat him up.
You know, so, you know, for me
coming from Compton, you know,
the police is a bad thing.
But, you know, like,
you grow up, you know?
You grow up, and you meet othe
people, you learn things.
And I have learned that there --
all cops ain't bad.
I don't think all cops are bad
I think there's a percentage o
them that are not trained well
You know,
it's really hard to say
because, like, we need to call
911 because we need the police
I mean, I just think
that we're going to
have to reform the policemen
I think that they just need to
be retrained.
Damn, Seth, it's really hard t
say what I really want to sa
because, you know,
you just got to keep
an even, balanced keel,
you know?
-Absolutely.
And I can't imagine how hard
that is, now more than ever.
I do want to talk to you about
some more optimistic,
more uplifting stuff.
We'll be right back with mor
Leslie Jones right after this.